U.S troops are being rushed to the
border to help deal with this
an increase in migrants that is expected
to swell next Thursday when the pandemic
era rule known as title 42 expires these
troops arrive as early as May 10th and
then in the coming weeks title 42 was
put in place as covid began to spread in
March of 2020. the rule made it easier
to expel migrants seeking Asylum now
that it's about to end it's already
putting a strain on cities like El Paso
Texas where hundreds of migrants are
camping outside homeless shelters
because there's no room inside I am
declaring a state of emergency in our
community Customs and Border Patrol
officials say they're preparing for as
many as 10 000 migrants to cross the
southern border every day that's nearly
double the daily average from March